foreign
Colorado Springs what's up J Money how
we doing
hey thank you for having me of course
what's up
um well I'm I've got a kind of a life
decision I need to make that's causing
me a lot of anxiety my oldest child is
showing early signs of depression that
I'm really concerned will eventually
escalate to something life-threatening
um we think that moving a couple hours
North near family and cousins that he
has a close relationship will help a lot
but I'm in this anxious situation where
it doesn't matter if I decide to move or
to stay I I have so much anxiety that I
can't seem to function I've lost 15
pounds in three weeks and I've I've
taken a few days off of works because I
just couldn't get myself to work
and I'm not sure what to do
before you do anything else
you have to commit to go getting Justin
well
because you're not
and you haven't been for a long time
have you
uh no it's been a long road it's been a
long time
I I am very hesitant to tell you what
I'm about to tell you okay because it's
not always causal
and I have no intention of heaping guilt
or anything like that on you are you in
a place where I can be super honest with
you
yeah
how old's your kid
he is 15. tell me about this stuff he's
experiencing because you hinted at he's
he's on the path to to Dying by Suicide
so like walk me through where he is at
where he's come what's kind of the
origin story here
uh so that uh go back in time last year
he was in eighth grade middle school he
uh about the the into the end of the
first quarter of this school year
um he he kind of we've noticed that his
grades started slipping and they took a
very steep trajectory down to to just
not passing in just about all of his
grades
um we we talked to him and he was very
complacent he didn't he didn't really
care
um when he has a lot of work to do he
gets overwhelmed and and like for
example on a Saturday he was doing a
math worksheet that was just front and
back maybe 16 questions and he was
working on it for six hours
um but it took him that long because he
was just Frozen
uh he couldn't couldn't handle it and we
we eventually we got some help we got
him a life coach we've we've started
having very strict consequences for not
getting homework done and he has
eventually gotten himself together he
has had he's gotten good grades
um and that's because we're on him all
the time he doesn't take responsibility
for it he he doesn't
um
he's still in that state if we were to
let up he would go back to it I know I I
just got to jump in here is that okay
this is a hard conversation to have
because we're not in person I don't like
having this over the phone okay I just
need to say that out for up front
because if you could see my body
language it's going to be very different
than what you're going to experience on
the phone okay
but you literally just called me
explaining how you are paralyzed and
Frozen with a decision to make
and my guess is that's been the course
of action
and so in many ways
your son is just simply
operating with the set of operating
instructions he's had in front of him
his whole life
and you're exactly right when I find
found out that straight A's can be a
trauma response to
I was set free
because that's how I've handled it I
don't have two phds because I'm not
smart I have it because I was that
broken and insecure that I kept chasing
and chasing something so that somebody
would tell me I had value
and so
the question here isn't life coach and
you stupid lazy little boy and I can't
freaking believe you
the response is sitting on the bed with
him and saying bro me too
my whole life me too
we've tried to help in a very loving way
it hasn't been like
I know I know I know I know
but he'll hear you
but more importantly than hear you he'll
watch you and he will feel you
and that's why I tell you before
anything here I mean obviously he's got
to make his bed he's got to turn his
grades in he's got to turn his stuff in
I'm not saying for a not accountable
home
but I'm going to tell you my home change
some of these problems that I was
reading books about and calling my
colleagues all across the country some
of the best experts in the world on some
of these problems
evaporated when I went and did the
counseling work that I needed to do
that is not true for everybody that's
why I don't like saying it because it's
not cause I can't point every kid who's
struggling with depression in the world
because their parents are have whatever
but the way you're laying this out for
me
sounds very similar
how long have you struggled with this
how long have you wrestled with things
being kind of low just kind of this time
it kind of anxious
uh it's
been forever oh but we've been married
16 years and it's definitely been for
all of that
where did you pick that up where did
where did you pick up that you were only
as good as your report card
um
I think I picked it up from my own
childhood we always had the standard
that
um we we don't fail in school we don't
do that we work hard
um in my childhood our parents divorced
and it was a fairly ugly divorce
um no abuse but emotional so
unfortunately not I'm gonna just invent
a map here that you and I would have to
spend weeks together to fully flesh out
but here's a here's a story I can make
up real quick
there's a nasty gnarly divorce and by
the way I want to take apart I want to
separate
we don't fail from we work really hard
that of that that ideal has got us where
we are as a culture because we have a
whole bunch of people that are terrified
and puckered up to fail which means
nobody's going all in
because everything's about the grade of
the piece of paper not about the effort
and the let's just go solve this problem
and we're going to make some mistakes
along the way companies that celebrate
failure do better than companies that
celebrate how shiny the exterior of the
building is
so I'm gonna imagine you as a
nine-year-old little kid or a
seven-year-old little kid who had one
job and that was to figure out how you
could fix mom and dad
and the way you kept every adult in your
life happy was getting a grade
and suddenly you outsourced your sense
of well-being by a performance standard
a scorecard and then that scorecard
becomes your child and if your child
behaves and your child does well then
you are doing good and if your child
drops the ball in the Little League game
and your child doesn't get grades X and
your child falls off a map then you're
failing as a parent that's your grade is
an f and you will work really hard
is that is that ringing a bell I'm just
making that up does that ring a bell
yeah I was I was also always the
Peacekeeper in the home as a kid that's
right
yeah
at some point you have to go do the
scary terrifying and I've been there
it's hard work of sitting with a
counselor
and asking yourself and walking through
with somebody
oh man it wasn't me that was so
unlovable this whole time
because what you're what you as a guy
who's worked with adolescence my entire
career
when you told me about your son's
performance following up a map I
instantly went to one of a few things he
found drugs
he is his body is shutting itself down
because he cannot keep up with this
performance standard he doesn't have he
doesn't have a he doesn't know how to
make you happy
or number three he is disconnected
completely unplugged he has no one to
plug into
I would say it's number three I don't
think that we have such high standards
that he's just overwhelmed by it I think
that
no no not standards not standards
let me say it um
my expectation for my kid my son
my expectation for him
is that he worked really hard with the
machinery and the wiring and the
resources he was just dropped into
planet Earth with
and he happened to have won the cosmic
Lottery and he was born to two parents
who are still married who love each
other who work really hard who treat
each other with respect and who both
have multiple graduate degrees
and one of his parents was an expert in
teaching kids how to develop cognitively
and then he ended up with another parent
that was an expert in taking adolescence
through
and so I've got very high excellent
standards because of
so I could care less about his grades
but he's gonna work really hard and I
know if he works really hard the grades
will more than take care of themselves
yeah
but that's different than you will get
an A
and all of that has to be anchored into
I love you so much
I'm with you
and most of that has come from me
sitting taking him to breakfast once a
week for the last few years saying dude
when I was your age I screwed this up
here
and here's what I did at work the other
day that I wish I could have back
that makes sense and so whether you move
or not what what how do you think this
move is going to solve all of this
um he doesn't have any friends he's very
close to his cousins and the move would
put him in the same school with his
cousins uh it would help him with some
social
skills and and the school is
significantly better it's a smaller
school it's highly rated it's it I think
it'd be a good good fit for him so I
think it would help him with the social
aspect but you don't want to do this or
you can't do this why
uh
I I think it's because
I of of some of my own struggles in the
past
uh we moved to our current area because
we noticed that every time we moved for
a job and by the way it took me 10 years
to get into a career I failed out of
college several times but I eventually
did graduate and I work as a software
engineer now
um but we noticed every time we moved
our mortgage would get more expenses our
living expenses would go up and so we
decided we're going to buy a house that
we're comfortable in a good area and
we're gonna
raise our kids with the rest of their
lives in this area
not only that but I felt comfortable
here I feel like the house was
comfortable I feel like our life was
comfortable my career was comfortable so
I spent the last 10 15 years being
Frozen in fear a lot of times and unable
to provide for my family not unable to
provide but struggle to provide
and and I feel like this move is going
to upend all of that like like for
example moving up a couple hours up
north is going to cause like a 40
increase in our mortgage and we're going
to be right back into that financially
unstable situation again and all here's
it all this tells me that you're not
okay
what you've done is you've created an
entire life around avoidance
yeah I am all about if you have an
opportunity your kids getting bullied
your kid is in a toxic school which
those do exist and you have the
opportunity to move them to a safer
Place great
you have the opportunity to move them
over into another school or whatever
that's I'm all about that that's fine
millions millions of people don't have
that option but that's great but what
you're going to do is you're going to
continue to reinforce that out there
somewhere is where everything is okay
and that's not where healing from
anxiety comes that's not where healing
from depression comes that's not where
any sort of relational healing comes
from none of that is extrinsic
that's not true if you're being abused
or you're an abject poverty
or you're being bullied on a daily basis
yes a change of environment is powerful
and huge and important
but you haven't healed you've just
created some a place where you can
bubble wrap yourself
where I'm currently at yes like yeah
I'm assuming you've been to counseling
and done all that stuff for years
uh
know this thing anxiety got so bad that
I finally did just in the last month or
so and and his first feedback was I
probably have chronic depression yeah
that's what it sounds like but I'm
there's no way I'm gonna diagnose you on
this thing but
um sounds like you've got some
significant work to do
and let me let me tell you this on the
other side okay can I give you like just
like I want to shine a Big Bright Light
Of Hope okay
all right
I'm a mess
in all the best kind of ways I hope
Kelly right now is waving her hand at me
like I am I'm a lot to work with and I
know that okay
but
on most days not all of them most days I
just fall asleep when I get home because
I'm tired
and on most days not all days
my kids come tackle me when I walk in
the door
and on most days my wife and I's
marriage is pretty good not always we
have seasons when it's tough and we get
off track and we have to like walk back
on the track again
but I'm a hundred percent confident that
if my boss came in tomorrow and just
said show's over you're fired man I
would be low I would be sad because I
like this I like being able to sit with
people and I like all the people I get
to work with
and then in a few weeks it would be on
to the next
and I'd be sad and I'd be angry but I
wouldn't be anxious and I wouldn't fall
off a cliff with into a black hole again
you see the difference
yeah but that has only come from a bunch
of hard hard work with a therapist and a
bunch of hard work with how I move and
how I eat and all that stuff that I
didn't want to deal with but it's
reality
sounds like you have good confidence
that you could recover and I I don't
know that I have that confidence that's
right and I I promise you I promise you
I did not have that before we started
this adventure
and so I the reason I'm telling you the
hope is there
I'm on the other side of it
actually I'm not on the other side of it
every day I'm just making some choices
it's like having bad breath man I brush
my teeth twice a day so I don't have bad
breath it'll come back in two days if I
don't deal with it
and what you've got to do is get those
that those skills deal with this stuff
in the past let your body rest finally
and then begin to just build it out
whenever somebody tells me that their
kid is struggling inside their own home
my question is always how's your
marriage my question is always how are
your finances and your stress and your
home how how are you
because so often not always but so often
our kids take their cues from us
and I love you enough to tell you
you gotta go do that hard work
so wherever you end up moving by the way
I think a 40 I wouldn't I wouldn't buy a
house then maybe for the next few years
you rent
and if that makes your heart start
racing I can't breathe and then we're
gonna go deal with that we're gonna head
straight into that storm
but if your counselor immediately
identified whoa you've been carrying
some bricks for a long time brother and
your body has been running low for a
long time let's go straight into that
let's jump straight into that and let's
be really honest and vulnerable with our
son hey son I've been dealing with
chronic anxiety for years and I didn't
even know it
and I think you've picked that up from
me
and we have some very special attributes
that the rest of the community doesn't
have and our bodies are pretty sensitive
to the signals in our world I'm getting
after it I'm gonna go work on it I hope
you'll come with me
you gotta make your bed and you still
got to turn your homework in still gonna
hold you accountable
but we've got a hard path ahead of us
and I'm going first
and when your kid has a ringside seat
too oh that's what a dad going on a
healing Adventure looks like and you
give them a road map and he's not may
not follow you right away
but he'll always know I know I know the
path I know a path out of here
I know a path out of here because my old
man took that first step
hang on the line I'm gonna send you
building a non-anxious life new books
it's going to give you a path and I'm
also going to hook you up with six
months of better help for free I know
you're in a therapist at home but I want
you to have an option that you can call
you can text that you have somebody else
that you can reach out to
please
continue seeing that counselor and do
the hard work you're worth it your whole
household is worth it
figure out the move later
but start getting well now